boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
very excited to still be doing
interviews at Co Fez the Congress on the
future of engineering software for our
second annual partnership with them we
are now sitting down with Erik Anderson
hello hey thanks for coming onto the
show
Darla really appreciate it I'm very
excited to talk with Oh a lot to discuss
Erik's backgrounds crazy he has been
doing he's now the principal of scale
venture partners for the last one and a
half years they have a four hundred
million dollar fund that's been making
investments into everything from
cybersecurity to developer tools to open
source technologies to now engineering
software so what are you talking about
that and we're talking about a journey
how he got here let's start with that
who are you how did you become who you
are today or were these major influences
on your life I so I I like to build
things maybe we'll start there yeah or
as a kid I loved science and maybe the
best way to visualize that I there was a
comment when I was younger I think it
was Hale Bopp do you I don't remember
Hale Bopp okay but I think it emerged
for the first time when I was like when
I say 812 or something I had probably
dozen pictures of Hale Bopp and all on
my wall
I got a telescope I've pretty into like
science and that sort of thing I was
astronaut was like the plan and that
didn't pan out I think I was afraid of
heights and anyway so eventually I
turned to engineering and that was kind
of what I wanted to build things make
things so it's interesting that the
influence came with both science and
building but that with you know looking
up at comets or that or that as a young
kid did parents were very involved with
helping your creative ability flourish
yeah I mean I certainly I like my
parents a lot so I should say yes to
that question but there was also one of
six kids oh you were one of six yeah
that's a big deal I was right in the
middle so I don't know that they were
paying any particular situation they
would say help me they did get the
telescope when I asked for it that's
great
but I don't know that they ever looked
at it with me totally was six of them
it's really hard to give it attention
plus working yeah support obviously I
mean I should tell my my parents were
amazing and before they see this and
think that I didn't give them enough
credit my dad was an amazing listener
yeah and like I feel like I could just
like explain everything to him and that
and he's a super smart guy that's got me
interesting a lot of things that's great
that's great yeah the the when you're
when you have six of them it makes it
definitely a lot more difficult to be
able to work and give each one of them
really important yeah attention an
ability to creatively flourish then you
know how did that lead you to Utah and
Stanford and Harvard how did you like it
go from engineering and building yeah it
took to the collegiate route where was
the what were you building yeah so I I
went to University of Utah I was my home
school and ended up in mechanical
engineering because I couldn't decide
between physics and computer science and
a couple other things and I mean the
first kind of thing I happened into was
I was working with my brother-in-law on
this bike that he wanted to build and I
I knew how to design it from my
schoolwork but he didn't and so I helped
him design this bike and it became like
a business for him that was like super
jazzed about this idea that we could
like make something and sell it I then
so I was kind of thought I would want to
do engineering in the way I hadn't
normally I don't want to be a designer
so much as I want to be like I want to
build companies and and is that kind of
you know I got excited about software a
bit and taught myself programming that
was back when half's were cool oh and I
had an Android phone so I wanted to
learn how to make Android apps when
people were only making iPhone apps it
seemed I actually want a little business
pong contest small one for this
particular app and it didn't work there
were some constraints behind it but it
got me excited and it was exciting
enough that when I interviewed for this
job at Amazon they thought that what I
was building was cool and it landed me a
job damn son
oh wow which was like kind of set me on
a course I think tours like so I was a
product manager in their cloud business
which I didn't know anything about but I
got this email every day that told me
how much money they were making in the
cloud businesses and this is before they
reported revenue I was like forget my
silly app these guys are printing money
like there's something special here and
I my manager left went to Google cloud
Wow and I eventually found my way also
to Google cloud thinking that was kind
of the ground floor or something big and
I always thought it would be awesome to
work at Google so I was just excited at
the opportunity and that's where I
really learned software so I was there
four and a half years yeah
working with a team of mostly PhDs that
we're doing like distributed processing
and I would I would have conversations
with them about what we should build
next and I would go home and just
research what everything they had just I
had worse I didn't understand things I
didn't guess right to try and like keep
ahead of what was going on you know and
maybe just to round out the story so in
the process of that I felt like you know
I wanted to be a builder and here I'm
working at like Amazon and Google these
big companies so I thought maybe was
time for me to look I started my own
company was talking to B C's about
things I was noticing things that their
startups to try and find a start-up but
that actually led to conversations about
joining a venture firm yeah so in the
process of trying to find a start-up I
ended up at scale venture partners yeah
yeah and it actually makes a lot of
sense because that when you you you've
said multiple times that you care a lot
about building companies and that versus
sometimes a lot of people care about you
know just making a design that works
really well for a specific aspect of of
a product or service and so when you're
at that end of the abstract spectrum of
a
a role in venture capital makes most
sense you with your background with your
when you're talking about the bike with
your brother-in-law and then the I'm
figuring this out slowly about yourself
as they're printing money at Amazon and
Google might help with their cloud
computing services right some crazy
stuffs happening with what with what
that means and how to make sense of data
and the application of quantum computing
intelligence to that and and and other
decentralization technologies of the
algorithm so that people can actually
use the right things at the right times
when they're not in silos all these
types of aspects are so critical to to
what's happening in the future and how
many years was a total at Amazon and
Google then Amazon was really brief over
there for like a summer in summer Google
was four years four and a half so almost
five years in like yeah yeah total and
total in cloud work and then and then I
loved also how you're describing your
story that when I do i do similarly when
someone comes on to our show that's at
the you know cutting edge of biotech or
neuroscience or blotching or wherever
they're at you know what I do is I do
similar work as you when they're just go
off and they're like but to all this
nuance and and depth and then I'm like
alright I need to go do more homework I
need to go and learn about these things
so I can be more well round and be more
well-spoken understand the future
technologies better so that's I love
hearing that and I hope other people
that watch also take that that meant
that mentality of humility and wanting
to learn and be open minded and go and
and the you know the Internet is such a
great tool now for you to be able to go
and do whatever thought you want yeah
yeah okay
now as you find yourself if if you're
like I want to build I want to build
companies you get into scale venture
partners now what is that like when
you're first introduced from you know
from from engineering and from the cloud
work that you did all the way into
venture capital when you first
introducing baptism what was that like
yeah I mean I think there were the folks
I joined had been a scale for some time
I think they were excited in some ways
had like someone who's humming from
industry some fresh ideas
so immediately ever interns to me it was
like Eric what should we do what should
we invest in and it's kind of deer in
the headlights we're like I mean I I've
thought about this to some degree but I
haven't never put my you know skin in
the game
excu to till this point it so at first
I'm just like I have no idea I mean I'm
qualified this answer good on the other
hand I'm like well no I just spent a
bunch of time looking at these companies
that I was going about to personally
invest my time in yeah and maybe that's
a good you know I was thinking
critically about what's gonna work there
I floated a few ideas and one I was
fairly jazzed about that we looked at
pretty closely and and within like a
couple months of being there the firm
had made an investment in the company I
was I thought we should like the timing
all worked out like they happen to be
raising we had I had an intro to them
and and I felt like I've suddenly hit
the ground running so that was exciting
I've since learned that doesn't always
worked out there we had a lot of great
ideas and the time he hasn't worked it
out but it's been a busy year and a half
okay so so what what does what does it
look like being the young guy that
people are like what should we invest in
and you're like thinking about what
we're civilizations moving towards where
you guys can really apply these you're
mostly focused on series a.b.c writing
yeah okay so these are like bigger
arounds yeah yeah companies have like
you know double digit employees and
they've got some revenue like they built
the product and a little bit of revenue
they probably don't have like a sales
team yet yeah the CEO is doing the
selling yeah yeah yeah
stage right yes okay and then so as as
this is happening and you're having all
these you know the other partners asking
you like what are you seeing like right
are we going what are your what are your
responses to yeah so I think at first I
started just regurgitating all the
trends that I'm seeing and which ones
were those I mean so open source was one
yeah like I think there was probably
class of investors who don't think it
makes sense to give away your product
for free and and there weren't a lot of
ton a lot of open source exits but at
the time actually in the year and a half
we probably seen more open source exits
of open source companies that anymore
and before I mean why there was just a
handful damn and that's great and so
yeah so that was like one thing that I
felt like what's happening but I I think
I hadn't yeah so I'm kind of occurred
hating these trends like open sources of
thing and you know server lists a cloud
infrastructure the poke approach the
kind of structure that makes it you
don't think about the server's is kind
of a thing and as I'm regurgitating
these I think I'm realizing that I
haven't thought about them the way kind
of BC's do in some ways like I hadn't I
really figured out are these defensible
markets are these big markets I was just
kind of rattling off the trends I saw my
friends we're excited about and so I
think quickly I started to try and look
at them through a new angle which was
like okay so which ones can you actually
make money in and I found that generally
the things my friends were excited about
were actually good
good investment areas but maybe not
always the case and then when when
you're when you're looking at like the
new aspects of these of these ideas
you're looking at you said like
defensibility you're looking at a
scalability market size all these new
ways of also perceiving the cutting-edge
technologies it that that adds another
lens to your to your kind of tool belt
of writing the world and that that that
makes it in a way it makes you more
well-rounded it makes you able to see
things in it in it and when when you're
listing you're listing these different
fields you know you open source the
amount of exits are were more in the
last year and a half which to me that
sounds very interesting because I'm
trying to figure out you know how can we
move towards that like open notebook
science yeah right oh yeah good yeah
yeah and then and then there's that and
then there's also the the you know what
was the other the second one that you
mentioned a service server list what was
so so so what a company wants to you
know to to not have to build their own
data centers they just use Amazon right
Google so but how does Google or Amazon
become server let or yeah yeah it's a
silly phrase but when you're Google or
Amazon you're still making a lot of
decisions when you interact with Google
or Amazon you're saying I want a server
about this size a virtual machine and I
wanted to have you know this much RAM is
such memory and when I say I'm ready
it's gonna take about 90 seconds to
become available that's crazy and it's
gonna yeah which is crazy that's right
and it's gonna charge me while it's on
for the next year until I turn it off
and once you start building services on
top of these things you're like well if
I don't you know why doesn't it why
doesn't the server automatically turn
off and I'm not using it and can't we
spin it up a little bit faster and
eventually if you think that way you
arrive the point of the bike why don't
you just charge me every time I need
that the moment I need the server for
just that moment correct for the
computation of the computation so if I
have a little website that
you know it looks up license-plate
numbers I don't know what it would do at
the moment I send a little accents plate
number and it returns the answer I just
pay for that moment of computation I
don't have to tell you how big a machine
I want you know the the more requests I
make it should just like become charger
you charge me more money and it should
scale to fit my knees and and that
that's kind of a notion behind
serverless it's okay no config noka
specify things and there's no oh okay
time spent spinning up or spinning down
okay got it got it basically though
there's still servers out there yeah
you're not thinking in terms of sir
that's good server less okay that's okay
it interesting so no config is
potentially a better way to yeah just
kind of like at as you need computation
you're just you're just passing along
the computation of the cloud right and
having that that cost come back for you
but of no one using your product you
don't pay Amazon any money correct yeah
right yeah yeah yeah so in that and then
that that saves lots of time because
otherwise the time setting up config
yeah and the time that it's on when
you're not using it all of us all of a
sudden right so interesting so that was
the second one and then you've also been
focused a lot on cybersecurity
yeah and that was a bit incidental I
mean I don't I don't think actually
security and privacy is more top of mind
for everyday folks but yeah we just had
a nebula genomics CEO on our show okay
and and the amount of genomic data that
the number one reason that people are
holding themselves back from from adding
their their their genomic data into into
for the masses on medical research and
all this stuff is because of the privacy
issue that that are
but it's a government involvement what
is the what is insurance involvement
what is the who's who's monetizing on
this data do I actually own it who owns
it I had all these questions that so the
prior yeah privacy in so many ways has
bubbled up to become this this extremely
massive issue but what are you actually
hiding should it go the way of China
should it go a global surveillance
should it go you know there's all yeah
any way I can go off but yeah yeah so I
similarly I mean when I first started we
were doing a deep dive on kind of GDP
are at the time and which is the kind of
European privacy policy that is probably
the biggest of its of our time and we
were looking for investments that could
help people satisfy GDP our requirements
meanwhile there was a ton of cyber
security investments that I there which
was kind of coming into the door that
and the more time I spend with them the
more I thought I you know I know
actually a fair amount of what goes on
with computer networks and how these so
so even though I didn't have security
background suddenly I felt like this was
an interesting area that I could weigh
in on that I was kind of forced to get
smart on and since then in the first
year of being a CEO we did I have helped
with four security investments where I'm
now board observers having you know at
the company every quarter helping build
the business it's been like now I this
is what areas I'm most excited about in
that you're going to do the most
homework right yeah yeah you've assigned
yourself tons of homework to go after
this process so that you can be at the
edge when the when the founders of these
companies are talking to you about what
they're building you can relate with
them right can and help be that that
you're hitting the tennis ball back in
interesting ways for them to build their
business I mean ultimately they're
looking for me to be a contributor
correct into the business and you know
and so I do my homework but but also
there's after you you help three or four
of the companies in security you start
to see that and you know here's here's a
great VP of Sales and here's a great
sales process and um and you know
so it ends up the experience I've had in
the past year has been super helpful and
the founders seem to be getting excited
about now don't teach us about what
these new cyber security investments
have to do with data and privacy yeah
and it may be more properly labeled like
security privacy compliance but okay
what we found is that when the companies
often have like a privacy officer
somebody who's kind of on point for
privacy but they don't often have the
budget or the organizational kind of
influence that the security team has
appeared a team has been at companies
for now a decade that's a lot of budget
a lot of influence and and their goals
are fairly aligned like securing data is
very related to to ensuring privacy
compliance on that data and so what
we're finding is that as we you know we
see selling privacy software almost all
often ends up coming drawing from
security budget and the security leader
becomes a stakeholder in the
conversation hmm and I see privacy
companies kind of expanding in the
security and security companies kind of
expanding in the privacy interests so
yeah it may it may be something that
consolidates to some degree time yeah
and you had that at the very beginning
you said you know it's a security
privacy right that is coming together
now when when it comes to securing data
companies that are aiming to secure data
they're complying with privacy
regulations that's usually happening
through cryptography is the process yeah
okay and then the the greater degree of
cryptography the greater degree of
privacy but then there's also this
process of wanting to make sure that if
the owner of the data wants for the data
to flow yeah it's easy to open these
valves and let the data flow so that's
is that part of that yeah I mean the the
types of regulations the compliance that
we're looking at initially is mostly
around things like if you have a breach
customer data is compromised you need to
notify the customer this is you know
Europe says this is how it should work
and it seems like the right way terribly
you even have the these Co centric
circles that prevent you get
notifications prior to yeah you should
you should prevent breach and in the
case of breach it should be kind of
limited in scope yes and and people
should be notified immediately another
kind of compliance regulation is if
somebody requests to be forgotten or oh
yeah from a database or they should have
the right to done so and for a lot of
organizations like no one no one's
thought to do that before or has the
capability to do that before and if
responding in an automated fashion in an
efficient fashion to somebody's request
requires a change and how they tool
their systems so a lot of the initial
investments we were looking at like how
to how do we satisfy those requirements
for companies that are now immediately
required to do this long term it's how
do we keep the data from the bad guys
but in the near term it's how do you
comply with regulation
yeah yeah and just a quick bit on your
on your perspective on the future
regarding this does it look like a
global surveillance is where we're
heading does it look like a complete
transparency on all things is where
we're heading I mean I like to think a
lot if we spiritually advanced ourselves
as a society we could more quickly
eradicate malevolence and not even have
to worry about some of these issues that
we have with with trust yeah so where
where do you where do you see that the
state of privacy yeah it's it's
ultimately up to I think the people's
how like if we don't get excited and
demand privacy policy from either our
governments or our company or our you
know
it needs to provide you know credit
services we're not gonna get it I think
there's there's power in data and for
big tech companies they they wield more
market power and have more revenue
potential with more data and is there
something to really be private about
this is an important thing you asked me
had it personally like should we be
worried about privacy like because as
it's just a thought experiment yeah if
there if we could spiritually advanced
there's no malevolence yeah what do we
really need to hide right yeah yeah so
then what would be the point of all the
cryptography and all yeah yeah of
restricted data flows and and
potentially open up even our ability to
move around the world with more ease
when there's no malevolence it's just
these are very important things to
unlock yeah assuming a world with good
intentions good actors yeah yeah maybe
they're you know I interesting thought
experiment to consider why we need
privacy I mean I don't know that it's
for me to say like I don't know that
it's an interesting counter question to
say just do people have a right to
privacy whether or not they can
articulate why they want it and should
we feel obligated to satisfy their kind
of request for privacy on the other hand
we certainly we haven't really asked
ourselves these questions yet like home
ownership in the United States is
largely public yeah it's all on the
titles and the deeds and you can look it
up but most people don't and I don't
think people realize that like their
names and addresses and sometimes phone
numbers are attached on public record
too like and you know and and who owns
vehicles is largely public today in some
ways I think I would love if a world
where we treated Social Security numbers
is public because the fact that we
pretend that they're private but they're
often leaked yeah makes it make it's a
tricky place to operate the Personal
Genome Project people just post their
genomes completely on all 6 billion
bases just right on yeah space so so
this is these are this these transparent
you know
deeds to your houses your yeah yeah
these are it's very interesting time to
explore thought experience like this and
how to how to get rid of some of the the
bad behavior some of the bad intent that
that exist to make it easier to live in
that in that trust filled environment I
want to ask about engineering software
sure yeah so what about skill is
interesting I think I mean we don't have
a bunch of historic investments there
it's a smaller kind of venture market
than what we have historically worked in
but part of your job is not to just keep
investing in the same areas because
there's always new opportunities and I
think there's a kind of emerging
opportunity in engineering software yes
between additive manufacturing and and
it's a couple technology of generative
design as well as kind of what I spoke
at Koko's today was about how there's a
pattern of automation in building
software and I think we're seeing
automation and building hardware anyway
all that comes together I think like
there could be some really big companies
here and in places that we haven't
normally expected to see them yeah
that's right yes yet the ones ability to
do yet engineering simulations the the
permutation 'el capability of artificial
intelligence just is vastly superior to
our human into competition Allah bility
to see the fit how functional can we
make a price in that space and that
doing that over and over again for
pieces to fit into it a whole that
generative to sign in additive
manufacturing that this is very an
interesting way to think about how a
general intelligence could potentially
be able to make more itself and and in
ways that humans are become a little bit
just oh not even and potentially can you
just become more yeah I don't know we
don't like using the word irrelevant but
yeah it's a human capital becomes it's a
complicated it's a very very complicated
yeah thing it's kind of like a little
bit of passing the torch to a to a
general intelligence it's a it's a very
competent but I'm glad that you're
watching this this well one thing we
found with we've seen automation come in
business software and in kind of our
research it not not to touch on
push-button issues but like what's nice
is that a lot of people a lot of these
jobs aren't that appreciated I mean like
ret very repetitious jobs that can be
automated by kind of rudimentary
artificial intelligence are not the most
enjoyable jobs lack of meaning and
purpose yeah yeah and but I think what
not to delve too much into policy but we
should also it at the same time we're
automating rudimentary things we should
look to retrain for all the beautiful
new things yeah I'm a huge advocate of
the hundred plus million jobs that are
being created but to get people into
those slots yeah is a whole complicated
shebang that we need you know augmented
reality and really these personal AI
learning systems that are like literally
no Allen's capability in biology and
they're really working with me on
understanding where I'm at and helping
me get to the point where I become very
relevant in the synthetic biology world
that type of stuff that is that that's
where you feel as well as that we're
we're we're moving potentially away from
some of the with the crosshairs of
software and the repetition work and
moving towards the the new creative gigs
but that we have this gap that we need
to get through of the degree of the
training for those do you feel something
yeah I mean I don't want to kick I don't
have a strong opinion you're one way or
another on what that future looks like
yeah but I I do think that everyone has
to some degree an innate desire to
create I mean I certainly did
younger I do now yeah ever I feel like I
talked to has it has similar feelings it
feels a bit human I want to create and
and not just do repetitious actions and
I thought the children and creative
design so yeah yeah yeah yeah so I'd
love to see it a way in which more you
know society much more people get the
opportunity to really treat that that's
that would be awesome yeah it's like the
the unlocking of the creative potential
of a human mind as well because it's
that kind of stuck sometimes in
repetitive maybe more a meaningless or
or less purposeful work and how about we
talked a bit on you know this is this is
crazy that this is a you know of four
hundred million dollar fund is is
massive but it takes a long time to
build up enough trust to be able to to
take in that much funding to be able to
go and make and make really good
investments then with this where do you
where are you seeing your time and and
and the the time of scale venture
partners being invested into the future
of technology where's our focus gonna be
that where is the main focuses that
you're feeling out yeah so we we've
historically spent most of time and you
know what we call business software
enterprise software and I in in the last
year or so we've dabbled in what you
know what you might call frontier
markets we've done some robotics but I
don't think we want to move too much
from our core of business software I
think
it's easy to kind of think about about
the future and not realize that most
people today have fairly you know Monday
9 to 5 lives and there's a plenty plenty
of opportunity to make people more
productive to to make businesses more
efficient yes with with with even just
kind of nuts and bolts software but also
artificial intelligence I think is
certainly me if I had a couple kind of
like within business software we're
going to look it's is vertical software
like instead of just horizontal tools
like everyone needs to CRM to manage
customer data well you know what about
for like the construction industry place
it's probably under invested in software
today yeah you know what what do
software solutions look like they're
real estate Healthcare I think I think
you know the vertical specific business
software is really interesting for
interest and then machine learning our
personal intelligence it can't be
overstated but probably is overstated
it's it's we talk a lot about it
were we're interested in areas I think
uniquely served by neural networks yeah
and I think it's easy to get excited
about machine learning general mystery
has actually been around for a bit and I
think the most recent advancement is
language interpretation computer vision
so I think areas that touch on natural
language and computer vision are
interesting in vertical markets and
horizontal markets yeah yeah yeah it's
good that you're you're going into
looking at healthcare and and real
estate and construction these are also
just massive fields that are probably
like you said they don't have as much of
the of the artificial intelligence
attention being placed on yeah there's
there's a lot of like you said work that
can be enhanced by artificial
intelligence and those in those spaces
so it's good that you're doing that
this has been a lot of fun I want to ask
you what would you say is an important
skill set for for for kids and for
adults and moving into the 21st century
to learn so sales I might jokingly kind
of say but like and the tails the
broader you know thing of sales is just
communicating I think communication is
something we're getting worse at the
same time we're getting better at so
many other things you know we don't talk
to people we don't form relationships in
the same way most software is still
adopted through at least enterprises you
know commercial software is through
sales all of my work is more or less
sales you know I'm either being sold to
where I'm selling and and yet I think
we've we've kind of structured the way
people think about training themselves
it's mostly around skills and those are
kind of often very kind of tactical
skills is about any number crunching
that sort of thing yeah
Steve Jobs is maybe like the most famous
innovator of our time and it's not
because he was like great at machine
learning or anything he was just
incredible at communicating his vision
of people yeah yeah it that this is such
a profound end to this conversation that
the better we can get at taking this
crazy human experience that we're living
synthesizing it into a really powerful
story that we can touch other people and
sell them on the idea of our mental map
that we're trying to replace the old map
of code of civilization with some new
code that people can really get behind
that that that skill is so critical
because it's funny cuz when we just had
you know great Brockman on the show a
co-founder at open AI that when when his
what his skill that he recommend
everyone needs to know how to program
yeah and you're like everyone needs to
know how to sell their vision yeah so
these two things kind of go hand in hand
right is one's ability to understand the
fundamentals of code along the
fundamentals of human connection and
rapport and love and compassion that go
hand in here yeah yeah it's so
interesting the way that these these
conversations end up going out Eric this
has been so fascinating thank you so
much for coming on in the shed teaching
us oh good god glad you had a good time
it's very important to us thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments blow on that
but so go and have more conversations
with people around you about what it's
like to invest into cutting-edge
technologies and have more conversations
around these topics also go and build
the future ever when manifest your
dreams into the world support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in go and check out the links
below to Eric's work the links to Co
fest and our links s simulation as well
thanks for tuning in and we will see you
soon everyone